une semaine les enfants turbulents
doivent rester dans une seule moitié de
la cour de récré les autres peuvent
jouer où ils le veulent une méthode
saluée par certains parents une punition
elle est douce elle n'est pas compliqué
du tout à la rue alors il faut punir
mais critiqué par d'autres pour qui la
mise à l'écart n'est pas la solution
pour moi c'est pas forcément la
meilleure solution pour aider l'enfant
allait mieux au total six enfants sont
concernés le but de ce dispositif
protéger les élèves ayant subi du
harcèlement plusieurs mesures avaient
déjà été imaginé comme la médiation sans
succès alors bien d'avoir de vouloir
punir la rca les harceleurs mais cette
méthode avait complètement déconnecté
des réalités le harcèlement aujourd'hui
il continue après l'école il se passe
sur les réseaux sociaux où il se passe
en dehors du du temps de présence dans
la cour de récréation ou en classe donc
pour moi c'est complètement inutile et
il faut simplement les exclure de
l'établissement être beaucoup plus dur
avec eux que les isolés sur une partie
de la cour je pense pas que ça va aller
les faire du harcèlement mais c'est une
première étape c'est une première étape
parce que la lada mal disait oui je
pense que c'est pas très bien ça va pas
vraiment aidé ses harceleurs en fait
mais le but c'est d'aider les victimes
pas les harceleurs donc au bout d'un
moment tu es à l'école tu te comportes
bien si tes parents t'ont pas éduqués et
que tu comprends pas le truc à l'école
on va commencer sa a vendu exclure parce
que l'exclusion c'est quand même mon
désintérêt des élèves ils sont petits
c'est en classe de ce1 se passe à ce que
j'allais dire
surtout d'être a priori non pas à priori
l'ont pas encore les réseaux sociaux
pour justement comment dirais-je faire
en sorte que ça n'aille pas plus loin
faire en sorte qu'ils ne gardent pas
ceci ces mécanismes toxique quand ils
arrivent au collège je trouve qu'en c1
quand tu es un petit peu ses limites
c'est le nouveau bonnet d'âne quand on
met un petit peu de côté que tu
sers à rien ça sert à rien sur quoi
à l'occuper les harceleurs et chose à
l'occuper vraiment ayant ou les études
sur quelques temps en tout cas informer
les parents bernard serin des petits
bonheurs ses missions hess comporte mal
c'est que ça s'apparente à du
harcèlement c'est pour savoir ce qui
s'est passé pour ça qu'on les exclus de
la course puisqu'il faudrait pas plutôt
à limiter ses moyens peut être de créer
de l'emploi roue de faire travailler des
psy ou des choses comme ça de créer des
cellules dans les écoles avec des
psychologues bien s'y essayer de
comprendre des enfants de les écouter
parce que je pense que
harceleur ils le veulent peut-être pas
ils ne comprennent pas donc il faut
peut-être essayer de gommer ça donc
peut-être plutôt que de les mettre à
l'écart et bédénik et des cellules
psychologiques de les écouter et de
gommer tout ça quand des comptes comme
ça parte on dit allez les petits sont
parfois très méchant mais bien ici pour
les autres c'est dur mais c'est pas dur
c'est pas du harcèlement sexuel
les éduquer donc vous vous dites non
vous moi je vais vous dire une chose
c'est que ce sera pris sur la prochaine
émission c'est de demander à aux gens
aux chroniqueurs ce qu'ils ont vécu
comme pire punition à l'école est
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui se passerait
les gens seraient choqués parce que le
problème agricole c'est qu'on ne pouvait
plus rien faire c'est vrai dire qu'à un
moment donné un enfant qui fait une
bêtise moi j'ai des souvenirs qu'on les
tire est bon mais tirer les oreilles
étape et qu'on met apple alors je vous
dis pas qu'aujourd'hui
dans les écoles un cp dans les écoles
j'étais punie j'étais collé or
aujourd'hui on ne connaît que les oui
aujourd'hui on ne colle plus aujourd'hui
on ne punit plus donc là on est en train
de faire quoi on est entrain
d'effectivement d'aider les parents qui
ont les enfants qui sont harcelés mais
l'autre côté vous êtes en train de de
marilyn est marginalisé des mecs
ensemble de les mettre ensemble qui vont
rien comprendre à cet âge là sauf que
tout simplement ils vont sentir un peu
plus marginalisés ils vont continuer à
l'extérieur de l'école allez c'est
terrible [ __ ] aujourd'hui leur effet
si une chose tellement important et si
on a inculqué les vraies valeurs aux
enfants etc et d'une vraie punition rien
après arrêtons de parler de suivi
psychologique de machin de machines à
répondre oui
c'est interdit
que ce soit
aujourd'hui
personnes qui sont marginalisés ce sont
les victimes moi ma fille a été victime
de cible de harcèlement scolaire est
allé déscolarisés donc aujourd'hui la
seule personne qui marginalise et c'est
ma fille c'est pas les harceleurs s'est
elle amusée la victime voilà et les
réseaux sociaux c'est pareil aujourd'hui
soit basse et c'est triste et c'est
triste que je vais dire mais ça en jette
par la fenêtre france coupe de réseaux
sociaux alors qu'à la base c'est les
gens qui harcèlent qui doivent être
punis les réseaux sociaux donc à un
moment donné faut pas renverser la
situation c'est déjà un bon début c'est
vrai mais bien sûr qu'il faut un suivi
il faut aller beaucoup plus loin je dois
aller beaucoup plus fort il faut y aller
très vite parce que ça prend une
thématique et je leur ai dit si vous
avez un problème faut parler à vos
parents bien cpe ou prof faut pas rester
seul parce qu'il ya la cisaille très
vite ça peut s'arranger parfois assez
rapidement mais comme on ne peut pas en
parler comme on n'ose pas dire voilà
j'ai un problème c'est on s'enferme on
arrive parfois sur des drames
épouvantables vraiment pas hésité à
parler